when did you didn't know you wanted to
get in the studio I'm feeling spired I
think again I was like dealing with a
lot of fear a lot of like um just was
afraid of like at that point just even
the process what am I gonna talk about
again you know is it gonna be received
you know I'm starting to compare with
other artists and I think when I went on
stage with ariana grande you know I seen
the reaction of how people reacted when
I went on the stage it was like okay um
he gave me kind of like a boost of
confidence and reminded me because it
been so long since I've been on the
stage just kind of reminded me what oh
this is what this is what I do this is
what I'm good at and I don't need to run
away from it I was like yeah I was
running away you know I think a lot of
us need to take that you know when
something's hard it's almost like we
need to run towards the the pain and run
towards the the hurt rather than run
away from it and I think you get kind of
healing when it comes to that 20:20
going forward into a new decade and I
think about from 2008 9 when it first
started for you right through I mean you
work non-stop and that was a decade in
full visibility of the world yeah yeah I
definitely have grown up in front of the
head of the world for sure but there's
nothing I mean just even thinking now I
mean what we're doing right now is we
are building or building a relationship
well you and I are doing right now is
building trust we're building huh you
know this isn't just I mean people will
see this and look at is that as an
interview but what we're doing is we're
just two men sitting down talking about
life and the human condition
you